you've been doing the card franchise for
a long time now 10 years as the
animation has progressed has your job
changed at all no it's still just kind
of roll into the studio and start saying
catch a yeah about it my favorite is
your Wow Wow
yeah yeah I wasn't even aware that I was
saying that so much it was pointed out
to me by the internet so are you ready
to become a superhero amongst kids it's
nice and very unexpected but you don't
normally get people cheering for an
animated movie like that it was kind of
insane and really hard to process and
crews originally was going to be a male
character and they changed how important
is it to have representation even though
they're cows and not human
oh it's absolutely important I think
that this movie tells a great story that
I think kids need to hear and be
reminded of it's the female character
her name is Cruz Ramirez we don't talk
about her being latina or a female to
talk about how talented she is you
realize oh it's racing doesn't have to
be only for men I mean she's a she's a
trigger she is so good that she teaches
the cars to be the best racers that's
incredible that's important I took my
two and a half year old daughter to this
movie and she was aiming for all the
entire time and really loved it and you
better believe when she gets older I'm
going to make her watch this again and
again because there's such a great
message with the with the Cruz Ramirez
character sort of like you as a person I
don't care what you are you can do
anything you want to do if you pick a
dream and you dedicate yourself to it
and I love that I love that idea I think
it's the storytelling I think the
writers are still on top of their game I
think they do such a great job capturing
the journey of these characters and you
know it's a little scary when inanimate
objects are so good at having feelings
and making you have feelings I feel like
oh gosh my days are numbered as an actor
but but it's I think especially
inspiring the storytelling is so human
and beautiful are you so excited to
train you I like a challenge
I call you my senior project
you